[Música]
eu estava aqui vocês vão amar calcinha
batavo elaborar um purê
rio a ir a deus a caminhar de
interessadas em outro tanto é que saí
dessa vitória
agora os segurados pra vocês e famosas
rock paulo que ali al faraj um ótimo
maravilhoso poder realmente a fazer
comercial bem aqui
em seis jogos no chão o centenário
francês
você sabe a língua ea problema rio
perderia toda a etiqueta ea aliança de
você está bem defendido por ele falou
que se interessam muito mas no final
pelo processo de atividade
todo mundo quer curtir
a gente acabou se envolvendo essa
inflação
por que criar é é aonde interior nós
então a gente ver te de santos
certas bases nossas para contentar os
outros então a gente acaba fugindo e
tendo pouca coragem bairro de água seja
uma condição seria uma idéia de fazer da
idéia e você só vai conseguir criar se
você puder
é muito importante você só consegue isso
não fará os políticos passando para suas
aulas críticas mimi dos outros é tirar
uma autoconfiança a copa você persiste
mesmo através da opinião dos outros
o primeiro que a gente forma já a
segunda é o que podemos ganhar aquilo
aquelas pessoas porque ela faziam as
cervejas compartilhadas
nós temos duas serventias e elas
surgiram muitos simbolismos como se
fosse um acordo formal a gente fez até
hoje é festa de casamento a moça de
batizado e jantar de celebração
intervenção porque é transformar são
paulo em uma falsidade e chacoalhar
paulista
aquele infeliz feita para que ele seja
curioso
em tempos de internet smartphones
vitória virá álbuns é muito popular e se
a gente usar essa idéia de metadona dele
ou um top ten pelo circunstanciado
a gente acaba afrouxando a nossa
criatividade
dizei de câmbio por exemplo as
intervenções
você pode jogar com um lugar têm estilos
variados tons um catatau esperado
mobilidade dele eu o lembrava a java
um sanduíche e bebeu cerveja lá tem de
ser um jornal o estado de são paulo uma
crocante folha tinha estão paulo quanto
o emprego
enrolada como se fosse o jornal recheado
de carne defumada e já o lateral à base
de pratos são o seu contexto
nossa solidariedade sem nenhum desses
elementos
não poderia existir falta um ano para
ser a minha existência
ainda essa dispensa é imprescindível que
você usa os seios grandes
o primeiro é preferência
todo mundo tem seus trunfos a cozinhar a
opinião dos outros é importante mas ela
não pode baixar o som pública do
criativo ozil que você goste mas não só
a segunda coisa é que você precisa de
técnica mas eu não sei fazer isso
aprendi 11 quilos e já fala porque uma
mãozinha e técnica além de ser meu ea
prova disso é o seu avanço - vencemos um
produto abundante de simples que se
usava sem habilidade que favoreceu
manejada
a breve trecho em que comemora hoje é
sempre urgente da matéria prima
orçamento sabe o que é ilegal
hoje solicitar que a batata
ela tem mesmo prestígio que aquele cabo
verde como normal que lhe assiste turma
de compra quando começa uma viagem a
curitiba
olha só o faraó principais países
produtores e fornecedores
foi o terceiro reich logo tem tanta
coisa boa
quem é uma pessoa em uma janela confessa
conhecer melhor o mundo agora tem 17
[Música]
então não é pagar uma coisa por esse
tema discutido o pessoal acha da onu
a mim um dos elementos-chave exigência é
o tempo de jutaí para sair para fazer
sair a jogar uma pedra é um dos 11 6
maneira ele é digital a se dissipar
parte baseada em tempo mas fazem tarefas
e rita começar pela guarnição
detalhe como em aos traduz a serget
infinitamente menos importante do que eu
[Música]
dá pra mamar tudo isso é a capital onde
andar é um ente já é uma aposta no
futuro de olho na prática
fazendo um ditador eu posso muito tinha
espanhol daniel prático usaram seus
maiores críticos
a fim de colocar capita mensal porque
assim você consegue objetivava mente
avaliar o que é manjada lugar famoso
restaurante o chamamento ele se ele
começa a temporada com essa sombra
temporadas faixa de 300 do ano
aproveitando assim nos falamos mais
importantes 12 situações metade da
equipe estava na metade e depois só com
os papéis
é um exercício de humildade muito muito
importante porque assim você dá
liberdade e criatividade ao mesmo tempo
de você a bolinha trabalho e até agora
pode deixar o primeiro de lava kessy tem
medo de mim mas para levar seu próprio
pequeno é maravilhoso surpresa
a gente ficava primeiro mas maravilhosa
hábito prisionais frutos deliciosos
balanço da instituição só deu por ele
o cérebro é manel tão grande de ouro
também teve confronto que não deixa da
tua vaidade emprego de qualidade a gente
percebe mais elevado
essa empresa é uma muito gostoso imagem
e tenho que falar em território lá e só
nessa comitiva o cérebro
ele faz a gente a gente passa para a
gente perceba idéias estranhas
tenho sentido
então com essa possibilidade de
transformar algo interessante e algo
mais confortável
a mágica escolhem para depois de ter a
tim como fund que reforça conceitos
errados
para você chegar onde você quer marcar é
difícil de fazer novela é mais adulto e
deixaram seus juristas mas a mesa mais
fácil retirar pessoas de crianças
a gente pode confundir sentir-me
explorando a nossa percepção de todos os
sabores pegando um vermelho retinha que
tinha você com seu carro a um parque aza
fazer uma textura que aparentemente é
preocupante
no final os vencedores na cia de ponte
nova uma meia hora
hoje eu tenho esses doces fabuloso está
grande
descobri uma coisa para uma causa
política véu você comenta ela consegue
fazer isso olhando esse dilema do estado
que é uma versão mais refinada quintal
essas frutas e nossas confeiteiro
além dos melhores do mundo eu tenho
poder de voz a percepção a pensar errado
as gostosuras falando em 12
a gente adora aquela analogia de agente
ativo segundo estômago luta sobre em ti
né eu escola completamente
é um ajuste quase todos os aspectos de
dois séculos é comprovado que a gente
tem no trabalho
só tem uma coisa dessas duas servas foi
um casal sai ambiental
em uma das disputas e brigas por
preferências afetar de rostos exemplo
nem implicado
imagino que há 12 milhões de anos a
gente vencer mais de um milhão de anos
mas a minha sugestão de raio x no
restaurante
onde os pratos não está vendo a gente
vai deixar surpresas no futuro um acaso
acho que irá convidar os dois séculos
inclusive tenho uma viagem aí a gente se
pega aí esteja aí o caminho de nome
incluído assim nos expandindo seus
horizontes transforma uma solução
aumenta o seu repertório
então muita gente devendo a mesa eles
têm uns mais pobres e criatividade
o mapa do ambiente
a gente precisa mudar isso
curiosidade fazer pontos nem se aquilo
[Música]
[Aplausos]